gets me every time
yeah I mean you're going for it I think
I know for efforts I mean yeah I mean
letting you make a film yourself I'll
just go like this hi I'm Kelly Marie
Tran I'm Quentin and Christie don't know
I'm Andy Serkis i'm ryan johnson and
this is the star wars edition of lads on
film john-boy a guy's probably the
biggest Star Wars nerd definitely John
boyega John boyega loves Star Wars and
he also has nine lightsabers John boyega
is a big big fan boy he has this huge
storm trooper
you wouldn't think he looks very very
cool the big nerd he's made every single
person in the cast sign we were very
much in the dark side world and I don't
think they came over to the dark side
world because they probably mean I've
been a Star Wars fan since I was a kid
so I know how passionate the fans are I
think at the premiere it's that's when
you really get to see everybody's
extreme passion and it's really really
overwhelming I don't have anything live
in Dublin and people are generally we
need you know the magical thing about
this film is that Ryan has really
beautifully captured carries performance
and we get to see her again and I think
that's really beautiful I got emotional
a lot of the film and obviously
particularly carries scenes because
they're really beautiful on their own
and then obviously they've taken
this extra and yeah this extra thing now
that we know that she's that she's a I'm
not gonna be that back so yeah
absolutely yeah I'm very much yeah
absolutely myself food I mean she is
such an individual kind of being and
such a a person who truly existed in the
moment she has a beautiful performance
it's a really emotional performance but
it will never not be strange and
complicated for me watching watching her
on screen in the movie I think that in
her own way Carrie and she's gonna be
immortal forever
so yeah kind of my pitch too and I still
can't believe they bought it they bought
it I gave him get to do it but they did
my pitch to Disney and Lucasfilm was
just let's do a new trilogy let's go
some new places meet some new people do
a whole new story
I feel so beard looking in here could
you tell I was like ah haha you're like
full-on having a conversation with me
and I'm just like